this is Detlef vessels big day he's
about to be elected the new chairman of
IG Metall the world's largest and most
powerful single trade union this is a
political event even Chancellor Merkel
is expected to attend a dimensions
people are tired of seeing so many
social issues have to be dealt with
they're seeing their jobs threatened by
temporary workers and subcontractors
with no legal minimum wage they're
having to work for six or seven euros an
hour they're working their entire lives
and not getting a decent pension these
are all issues where I'll say right now
something has got to happen via Sophia's
[ __ ] antivirus pasion over 450
delegates have arrived from all over
Germany they represent more than two and
a half million members no politician or
CEO can leave IG Metall out of the
equation wherever fair pay and better
working conditions are at stake the
union has something to say about it
detlef petzl is a tool maker by trade
over the past few years he has worked
together with his predecessor to
overhaul the Union now aged 60 vessel
joined IG Metall as a young man today
he's the top dog it's a position that
will take some getting used to I think
lots of things will be getting a lot
worse for the workers in the coming
years and IG Metall has to make itself
heard vessel is very straightforward
he's got very clear goals and ideas and
he's not afraid to ruffle feathers I
don't know whether it's what the
rank-and-file wants or not but it's the
right path because diversity
detlef pencil comes from IG metals
left-wing he says he wants to give the
Union back to its members with more
power to the grassroots and fewer
officials on the executive committee but
vessel strategy has already made him
enemies many activists present his
cutting posts in the Union hierarchy the
question is will that cost him votes
the final count gives him the support of
75 percent of the delegates it was the
worst result for an IG Metall chairman
in 10 years I was aware that the mood
among the delegates was somewhat
critical reform processes always provoke
condemnation and polarization yes I was
a little nervous but everything's okay
now Miss Universe I by yet to satisfy
water many union members hope that their
chairman will take a very clear line
with government representatives in the
future even if it means a confrontation
with the Chancellor Angela Merkel wasted
no time congratulating the new IG Metall
chairman and he wasted no time getting
straight to his pet issue subcontracting
where workers are paid below minimum
scale
that's up Albert and the unemployed work
on the same project a successful country
a humane country that means differences
of opinion but even so I'm looking
forward to a fair a positive and
sometimes controversial discussion soon
detlef pencil took the opportunity to
acquaint the Chancellor with another of
his concerns the possibility of earlier
retirement for more physically demanding
jobs let us go home at age 63 we've done
our duty in the fifth catan clear be
straight forwards make compromises but
no sellout compromises that's my motto
traitor the new IG Metall head has two
years to put that motto into practice
before the next election